>>Karen Gilpin: By showing them
that what we're doing
in the classroom is affecting their
community and helping their community,
they see its value, and so
they're willing to buy-in,
even if the academics get a little hard,
they're willing to work a little harder.
>>Dana McCauley: Any problem isn't really
a problem, it's an opportunity.
Right? It's an opportunity
to learn something.
They may not be the hero that rides
in and solves the problem completely,
but they get a piece of it.
They can be part of the solution.
>>Jacob: This could be right over there.
>>Dana McCauley: You know, with our agriculture
program, in tying in the chores
that they have to do,
they live that every day.
>>Jacob: We're actually building
playgrounds for the animals,
because we've found that they have
been trying to jump over the fence.
>>Carrie Hordubay: The kids really started to
think, "[sigh] They're kind of bored,
why are they acting this way?
Why do they keep getting out?"
>>Kevin: They hardly have anything to
play with, and sometimes they'll get
on the watering containers.
>>Dana McCauley: The one rain barrel,
when it got knocked over,
the goats started jumping over it.
So like, "Well, huh, they like that.
What else could we make?"
So that's when we came
up with the idea of,
"Maybe they need some
playground equipment."
>>Carrie Hordubay: Ladders here, slides here.
Let's see what we can design.
Kind of tie our engineering
piece in and problem solving.
>>Jacob: We had to draw our own design,
and it had to be from everybody's idea.
>>Kevin: We're trying to build the model
like we have it on paper,
but like in 3D.
>>Sarah Deacon: And they're going to build this
model, and then they're going to get
to see the actual thing built.
>>Jacob: Professionals will pick the
best one to be put inside the barnyard.
>>Carrie Hordubay: I had them tell me what
materials they thought they needed.
>>Sarah Deacon: So they're already
collecting stuff.
Do we have popsicle sticks?
>>Carrie Hordubay: We have popsicle sticks.
Glue?
>>Sarah Deacon: Mm hm.
I'm curious to see what they're
going to do with the peanut butter.
The other thing that we might want
to provide them is a model animal,
so that they can get this to scale.
>>This is how we're going
to scale our model.
If you are making something for
the goats or sheep to play on,
this should probably fit on it.
>>Students: [talking excitedly]
>>Sarah Deacon: When it's something where
they know it's gonna be out there
in the schoolyard, they're
totally engaged with it.
Because there's also a sense of
pride, like I helped do that.
I mean, they're going to have this
cool product at the end, but they're--
hopefully will also remember, "We
built models, we worked as a team."
>>Student: Well, I don't think
they would need a feeder on there.
>>Sarah Deacon: "I got to use a saw, I
learned how to use a measuring tape.
You know, I know what a 90-degree angle
looks like because it's over there
on that playground for the goats,
and I see it every day I'm outside."
>>Broken.
>>Yeah.
>>You can use some of these.
>>Karen Gilpin: Well, one of the
standards for first grade is
that students are aware
of the things around them.
>>It's wiggling to get the skin off.
>>Ohhhh!
>>Karen Gilpin: We have been tagging
butterflies for several years.
And then in the spring, we didn't
see many butterflies around here.
So we've talked to park rangers,
they have seen that this
area was low in milkweed.
>>Caroline Blizzard: We talked about,
you know, what's happening
with the milkweed habitat loss,
and their milling patterns,
the climate shifting, all
of that that's playing in.
And they really understood it!
>>You guys are going to
help us this year by helping
to plant their favorite plant.
>>Students: Milkweed!
>>Caroline Blizzard: Milkweed!
Why do they need milkweed?
>>Student: To lay their babies.
>>Caroline Blizzard: They lay their eggs.
Give me five!
All right!
>>Karen Gilpin: We've read both informational
text on butterfly migration,
fictional text, social studies.
We have tracked butterfly
migration on a map.
All kinds of things.
Math, when we put the milkweed
here in the ground today.
>>Caroline Blizzard: All right!
You guys tell me which
one is three-quarters.
>>This one.
>>Caroline Blizzard: All right, so just
about like this, all right?
And then you're going to lay
a seed right on top of that.
>>Yeah!
>>Caroline Blizzard: Can you find one?
Here, spread them out, there you go.
>>Caroline Blizzard: They really understand
that it's not about just what's happen
at Crellin, or even in Garrett
County, you know, you can ask them,
"Do the tornadoes in
Texas right now matter?"
And a second-grader here will you, "Yes,
because that's where the
Monarchs currently are."
>>Good job.
You need some seeds?
>>Okay, boys...
>>I think they're starting to feel
like the things they think matter,
the things that they do matter.
Even when I'm eight.
Even when I'm nine.
>>Sarah Deacon: Because they're so
invested in it, and really engaged
in the process, it really cements it.
It's something that they'll remember.
>>Carrie Hordubay: Yeah, connections
to their outside world only
make learning more meaningful
and more purposeful, and more lasting.
>>Karen Gilpin: We're teaching them
to be people, important people,
who can do anything they want to do.